USANA does have a problem they will let
you IV you just not very much what they
don't say is how often you can do that
and that's the flush EPO the usada
taught the world how to beat them nobody
really understood the way to get EPO
grow through your system is to IV it and
flush it with an IV we learned that when
they banned the IV who saw to taught
people how to beat them that's so
interesting man I forgot about that
that's all that Lance did nobody could
figure out how Lance was beat it even
the fellow cyclists like man how are you
doing I see they test you all the time
well his answer was he flushed it with
an IV he was kind of the first to the
party to realize that you can get the
effects and the benefits long after it's
out of your system